welcome to this video shoot seunghye
from china chinese flag at least so
let's see so you maybe try something
else you can also play the squinty
phones has been played by cars in a
couple of times hmm
but quite shown so c4 am I think this
one ok
yeah he obviously doesn't want to want
to have Bishop g5 coming understandable
ok I'd like to play Bishop e3 92 c 4 but
now that i think of it probably need
this as well trying to get the Night
Journey doing oops I completely
forgotten about 250 what the egg
yeah this makes you look like a real
idiot as white just allowing d 54 for a
better game for black hmm
gap like it's just better now two
bishops outside to exchange Queens I was
made on g2 threatened it's just a very
nice position now from black okay let's
see how to how to defend maybe maybe
he's playing if I am if ice it's also
good for for black but at least it gives
some stability to my position that it's
fairly closed and I have some some some
decent job positions for my pieces you
know I'm not so sure that that he's
playing this in the best possible way
it seems a bit a bit premature maybe in
general you want to advance and and get
and get them and get an advantage in
space but then it's not it's it's a
matter of proper timing and I'm not sure
that this is so properly properly timed
can i play h4 maybe this is ambitious
trying to use the g file is not not so
not really concerned about all that he's
intending to play Bishop c5
came he could have taken the pawn on
each for me huh would have been
interesting but ok let's see what what
happens now Bishop c5 is of course
interesting I was thinking I could maybe
play ok for gypsy 5 mm I could hmm
interesting
I could also just try to use the H file
to do to get an attack or a form it's
not bad probably not bad Bishop c6 you
should see six maybe
I can play Bishop c6 look-see for that
but it isn't so terrible come on
I managed to get just exchanging looks
would be a perfectly okay check check
with this not shown
okay you should be five I can play Roxy
three yeah or this one check the others
isn't so bad isn't so bad
come on let's try to get rid of this the
stuffy on the kingside activate the
night once the pawn on f5 is gone i can
i can probably activate the night only
from ikea 5 is a good move camp licking
a fire mmm then I cannot take ear form
okay i can i can i can take over this
this i don't understand check always
check check mmm interesting let's see
my king is also dangerous IAM
time morning
the other agent seconds left check
yeah should be at least the draw check
check
black resins really is it when I'm right
i was just playing the move i needed to
play it's not just a draw why does he
resign I don't get it check check check
this is sold cassia if i go here he he
gets the tempo under and this is the
draw this is this typical draw with the
a pawn or the h-bond it just resigned in
the drawing position this is nice yeah
it should have it should have been in a
draw i think all along but yeah i don't
know i mean i was in a very bad
inevitable better bad position I on the
right in the opening around here yeah
this is the kind of the dreams of slowly
in position for black kids got two
bishops it's got this additional porn in
the center yeah now we got this
protected passer but I'm not so sure
that this is great it's black it's
better I am too no I don't want to argue
about that but maybe it it was better to
play it in a bit more and a slower
fashion just slowly improving around
here it didn't feel so terrible to me
this is of course a gamble he could have
taken and the computer says you should
take and black is clearly better yeah I
didn't see King edge five I was only
thinking okay if it takes this is this
is quite nice very good play
but I didn't didn't see that one yeah
it's good for lucky you will at some
point probably be able to take yeah
Dwight Twitter strange game anyway and
he resigned in a drawing position at the
end alright thanks for watching